seul ou en groupe la rando a du succès
en 2021 56% des français déclaraient
pratiquer la randonnée pédestre et la
marche loisir soit 27 millions de
personnes et c'est dans les années 70
que la pratique a commencé à s'organiser
et si le temps était venu de découvrir
la marche au moment même où la vie de
l'homme moderne sa durée de moteurs et
les mécaniques semble devoir se dérouler
une fois pour toute au long d'un rail
d'acier entre deux garde-fous le béton
en pleine sociétés industrielles les
français ont besoin de grands airs alors
le comité national des sentiers de
grande randonnée diffuse cette idée un
jour deux chantiers oui jour de chanter
ces malades schiste notre comité la
devise est connue des marcheurs
expérimentés mais l'organisation entend
faire de la marche une passion française
nous sommes une fédération des
associations de plein air ou de jeunesse
qui s'intéressent à la randonnée je
crois que ça ça permettra ainsi damé de
plus en plus de français à la marche et
à la randonnée petit d'abord et grande
randonnée ensuite alors il faut guider
les français pour ça le comité fait
appel à des clubs de marche
départementaux et régionaux pour tracer
des chemins certains sentiers de grande
randonnée existent déjà comme le gr iii
mais il en faut encore plus on regarde
d'abord sur la carte qu'elle pourrait
être l'intérêt de fuir un sentier dans
une belle région on regarde donc des
particularités géographiques par exemple
une vallée curieuse ou au contraire une
région abondante au monument temps
un itinéraire gr ne doit pas emprunté
plus de 30% de routes goudronnées c'est
une des règles du comité autre signe
distinctif les balises qui jalonnent les
sentiers elles sont installées par les
bénévoles nous sommes chargés de le
baliser c'est-à-dire défaire des maires
de france et des marques qui permettent
aux randonneurs ou bonheur de se
retrouver facilement sur le sentier en
somme de pouvoir marcher de pouvoir en
donner en ayant l'esprit tranquille
cette année-là en 1971 le comité
national des sentiers de grande
randonnée est reconnue d'utilité
publique par l'état au fil des ans le
nombre de chemins balisés augmente le
nombre de marcheurs aussi et il
participe à l'économie locale notamment
pour les propriétaires de gîtes d'étape
en 1973 cet homme assisté à cet essor
c'est simple et vous tâchez de vous
arranger pour dormir du mieux possible
il ya beaucoup de randonneurs maintenant
oui ça a pris des proportions depuis
deux ans il ya deux ans a été passé que
37 dans magic parfois tout aussi fier
mais l'an passé cherche un grand
bond en 1978 le comité devient la
fédération française de randonnée elle
entretient aujourd'hui près de 115 mille
kilomètres de sentiers de grande
randonnée et compte deux cent quarante
cinq mille adhérents répartis dans toute
la france
[Musique]